Optimal, minimal. At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I don't know how else you
would pose a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over metal.
This episode is brought to you
by fresh books, man. Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast
and readers in mind love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting
with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by
more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track your
time, and get paid very, very quickly,
which suits the needs of a
lot of freelancers, a lot
of entrepreneurs and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit
card and debit card.
So all of the things you buy automatically
appear in your fresh books in the
right category, so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy, makes invoices easy.
It makes your life easier. And also
in fact, I would recommend a pdf. Uh,
they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf a while back
called breaking the time barrier subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential
so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work
week with a service business?
And the story in that Ebook, it's pdf is
the short answer is really, really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
check it out,
but also why not test out freshbooks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free
trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter Tim Ferriss, two r's and two s's
in the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very
little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward
slash Tim and try it out because it is a
very good product and I think you will
find it simplifies your life and joy.
This episode is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com the world's largest on
demand massage service.
I have been broken so many times over
the years that I usually have body work
done at least once a week. I have a very,
very high bar for this type of thing.
And I was very skeptical of sue
with until I tested them. Not once,
but I would say at least a dozen times
around the country in different cities.
I do not accept anything less than
excellent for any type of soft tissue
treatment.
And uh,
would not suggest that you accept
anything less than excellence.
So I can affirm personally
that sooth delivers a licensed,
experienced and above all effective in
my book massage therapist and the comfort
of your own home hotel or
office in as little as an hour.
So you can think of it as Uber for
massages available and 55 cities at this
point across the US, UK,
Canada, and Australia.
So you can relax just about any time,
any where.
And I've tried many different types of
massage that they offer in the process is
super, super simple. Download
the sue, the APP, that's s o t,
h e or go to [inaudible] dot com
choose the kind of massage you want.
You can select Swedish sports, deep
tissue, or even couples massage.
I usually do deep tissue myself or I'll
do couple's massage and then tell both
of the therapists that I'm actually
intending to get a four handed massage
instead of it having two people get
to him massages, if that makes sense.
Then you set the length of your massage,
whether 60 9,120 minutes.
If you're looking to get fixed,
I usually do 90 or ideally 120 you select
the gender of your therapist and then
boom, you're done and you will
see who picks up the call.
The service is available from 8:00 AM
to midnight and sooth brings everything
that you need to create a spa experience
in your home and the therapist handles
all of this. The massage table, linens,
oils, music, the whole nine yards.
So try it out. Download suse,
and as a listener of this show,
you'll get $25 off of your first
massage when you enter the code.
Tim 25 all caps,
t I m two five again,
download the [inaudible] app and use
the Code Tim 25 for your $25 discount.
Hello boys and girls.
Dot. Masica by arrows.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers of all different types from
philosophy, chess, business,
entertainment, you name it,
academia research to tease out the
habits, routines, favorite books,
favorite cereals, morning
routines, whatever it might
be that I think is tactical,
practical that you can
apply to your own life.
And my guest today is Whitney
Wolfe heard on Instagram,
you can say hello at wits
Wolf Heard W. H. I t.
W. O. L. F. E. H. E. R. D.
She is the founder and CEO of Bumble,
one of the fastest growing social
networking apps in the world.
She launched bumble into those and 14
is the only dating platform where women
make the first move and in three
years counted out 36 months.
Her vision has led to bumbles growth to
more than 28 million users worldwide.
In 144 countries.
Bumble launched bumble BFF,
best friends forever,
bumble BFF and 2016 as a friend finding
feature and launched bumble Biz twosies
for professional networking
in 2017 Wolford was named
to Forbes 30 under 30 list
for 2018 and has recently been on the
covers of not just fast company but also
Forbes and wired magazine's
without further ado,
please enjoy this conversation
with Whitney Wolfe heard
Whitney, welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me. A local,
a local
Austin, Texas. Yeah,
so I wanted to start at the beginning and
for those people who are familiar with
the, a bit of the genesis
story and also the name itself.
So how did bumble come to be?
Why did it come to me?
So bumble is somewhat of a unique story
in the sense that it wasn't just a
singular Aha moment somewhere.
It was really a response to a
couple of different things in life.
And then there was a little
bit of serendipity involved.
I had just started becoming the kind
of the center of this attacking,
you know,
violent internet abuse and all sorts of
strangers and random people online were
just ripping me apart all day long in the
media and in the comments sections and
on Twitter. And it sounds silly to
think that that could affect you.
Um,
but it devastated me and it made me just,
it just made me so depressed and I started
to realize that there was something
wrong with the Internet.
I started to realize that the lack of
accountability on these social networks,
that was a real thing and there was a
real risk to that. And I was, I was on,
you know, I was a perfect example
of how dangerous it could be.
And if I at 24 who had already
had somewhat, you know,
successful career and had great friends
and family around me and I still could
barely get out of bed and I could barely
see straight, I mean, it, it just,
it depleted every,
every ounce of confidence that I've ever,
ever had.
It scared me for what it would mean for
a 13 year old or 14 year old or 15 year
old who was in junior high
going through this. Right.
And so I started to really understand
the danger of the internet and it was
around that time that I started thinking,
what am I going to do next?
Because obviously I'm not going to,
you know,
just do nothing at 25 after being part
of this really high growth startup and
having this,
you know,
awesome exposure to so many different
areas of the tech industry. Um,
and so I was going to start a female only
social network where you could only be
kind to one another, so you could
only share complimentary behavior.
And the thought process behind it
was compliments are contagious,
just like hatred is contagious. Is
it going to be called mercy? Yeah.
Thank you. Right. So it was, it was
supposed to be a kind of social network,
which had never been done.
And um,
it was around that time that things kind
of parlayed into where we are now. Um,
my now business partner on bumble,
who's been a huge force and you know,
bumble coming to life and, and
the, the course of bumble, he, uh,
tried to hire me as his
CMO at his dating company.
He has this huge dating company that's
the match of Europe and South America.
His name is Andre have and ever,
right.
So James Bond, um, yeah,
he's, he's pretty awesome.
But he,
he wanted me to go run marketing and is
dating company and I thought he had lost
his mind. Um, and so I told
him what I was going to do.
I'm going to start this new way,
this new age of social media.
And he was like, no, you're not. You're
going to do that in dating with me.
And I was like, you've lost your mind. Um,
but we actually ended up talking through
it and the more thought I gave to this
new concept of a dating app that could
be engineered for women by women,
um, the, the need became more apparent.
And so that's how I shifted from this
concept of mercy into what is now bumble,
which was, you know, very much
similar concept if you think about it,
you know,
creating a brand rooted in kindness
or product rooted in good behavior and
really putting women in charge of that,
creating the female internet. And uh,
that was really the beginning of bumble.
It was the first name of a
bumbler word, Moxie. Moxie.
Yes, it was, I really wanted it
to be moxie. Um, so you know,
for anyone that's familiar with that word,
it insinuates that someone
has gall or guts and is brave.
And because bumble was going to be this
platform turning society on its head
where women were going to make the
first move, which according to society,
that's not something women should do.
Definitely not in dating, right? I mean,
it's a tale as old as time men
do that men need to go first. Um,
or so society said and says, um, and
so mocks who's going to be the name,
but I couldn't trademark it.
Why couldn't you trademark it?
There's somebody else had totally
trademark every corner of it.
It's actually a soda somewhere.
And then there's some big PR firm or
some consulting agency that's trademarked
the heck out of it. And I couldn't do
it. So how did you land on bumble than,
I actually hated the name bumble
at first I thought bumble.
How did it occur to you? And I did not
think of the name bumble. Actually.
Someone on our team or early team did.
And she had actually called her husband
a bumbling idiot and she's got this
British accent. She was like,
you know what about bumble?
Because we'd all been
searching the internet.
We literally putting random letters
together to come up with words and mean
anything. What were the other
top contenders? Um, oh goodness.
Yeah, because women were going to
take the leap and make the first move.
And actually leap year is a very
interesting story. So in leap year,
folklore says that women would
propose to men during leap year.
And so we thought leap and then we,
you know,
we played with Sadie for
like Sadie Hawkins dance. We
played with several names.
Hawkins, you don't know what the city
Hawkins dances or surprise. Okay.
This is awesome.
So the Sadie Hawkins Dance started in
the 1930s and it was based off of a
cartoon by al Cap where these women during
leap year would make the first move.
Essentially they,
they'd ask them men to marry them and
this got consolidated into a dance that US
school system started putting into place
and it became so popular, you know,
the Sadie Hawkins dance,
they'd wear the poodle skirts and
the black and white shoes. Okay.
You're going to have to look into this,
but
no. Is it a dance? It's
not an actual dance style.
Like a mating ritual dance.
No, it's, it's like a school dance.
So you have the prom, right? Right.
And then you had the Sadie Hawkins
dance and the Sadie Hawkins dance was
different from the prom because boys ask
girls to the prom girls asked boys to
the Sadie Hawkins dance.
They asked the boy to the
dance and something really
interesting took place when
the Sadie Hawkins dance went into effect.
It became so popular,
they made it a national holiday and it
became so popular because parents felt
that it was a safer option because the
way the boys behaved when the girls asked
to the dance was much less aggressive.
Girls were not crying, feeling left out.
So it recalibrated these gender norms
around flirting and dating and courting.
And so that was a big inspiration
behind bumble. You know,
when we were thinking about
women making the first move,
it was almost the digital
rendition of that. Did you,
you did or did not like bumble them when
it came up? I did not like it at first.
And I'll tell you why bumble sounded
like fumble. You know, you were,
you're fumbling through a
dating experience and we
wanted this to be an app that
was empowering for women where
they felt confident and in control.
And it was not until all of these really
cute catchphrases start started being,
you know, coming, coming up, people on
our team and friends when, you know,
we're asking, what do you think about
this name or this name or this name?
And all of a sudden, um,
these catchphrases were
coming up like, you know,
be the Queen Bee of bumble,
find your honey on bumble.
And it was in that moment that
we said, okay, this is it.
This is brand ability.
This is how you brand something.
And that was that. Was it
off to the races? We went,
yeah. If it sticks, it sticks.
One of the first things I ask proofreaders
who are typically friends of mine who
are writers or lawyers because they're
really good at spotting sloppy language
or words that don't need to be. There are
things that are confusing. In any case,
one of the first questions I ask after
they've read a chapter is I will give it
some time. So like a half hour have
a cup of coffee. I'll say, okay,
what do you remember?
And I'll see what,
I'll see what the first few
things are that come to mind.
It's really interesting.
A lot about top of mind like yeah,
I don't think about it too hard.
Like top top line. If it takes
too long, it's like, all right,
I need to rework the entire chapter.
Now,
how many people roughly at
this point use use bumble?
And I know there are many different,
many,
many different metrics and
was he give about it? But we,
we look at kind of overall user
base in terms of registrations.
How many times has somebody
download our platform?
How many people have
registered for our APP?
We've had over 29 million registrations
now in just over three years.
It's a lot of people. That's
good. It's a few people. Yeah.
I saw the part of the beauty of the,
of the approach,
and I know that there's a lot of
complexity hidden behind a very simple
interface. Believe me, with the amount
of time that I've spent with startups,
I started using bumble very early on.
I mean sort of,
I'm not going to call it Alpha or Beta,
but very early on,
and what I realized very quickly is
that by having the woman make the first
move, you also remove one of the biggest
pain points. And you know this for men,
which is women receiving
500,000 unwanted messages.
And even if prince charming
is hiding in there,
even if you are the ones she would
pick, it's too much noise. This,
the signal to noise ratio
is so unfavorable that as
a guy you could put out a
hundred messages and get
zero responses and it,
it just cuts out that first
leg of wasted work completely.
So thank you for that.
Well that's awesome feedback.
It's interesting that you highlight that.
That just plays into these
gender dynamics. You know,
women from the time they start thinking
about who they like or having crushes,
it's that it's going to be inbound,
right?
They were trained to think
that's going to come to us, that,
that the boys were supposed
to chase the girls and,
and then that turns into the
men chasing the women and,
and that we're supposed to essentially
play hard to get and not give in. Right.
And so when the good guy does show up,
you oftentimes miss that given those,
you know, those broken dynamics.
And so yeah, when you do flip
the switch it, it does allow,
it does allow for better and
more genuine connections.
So people might be listening or watching
and they've read a bit about your story
and you're on top of the world. Right in
so many ways. Stepping up to the plate,
hitting home runs every time out that
but you mentioned when we got started
this, this depressive
period, this dark period.
So I wanted to read something that I
found in the course of doing some research
and it may be a paraphrase
but I think it's,
it's somewhat accurate based on checking
with you beforehand but I don't know
the elaboration.
So the quote here,
it's from refinery 29 and it talks about
how you wanted to build a company that
encourages empowerment,
confidence and respect because when you
have self respect it's really hard to
get you down. This is the part I
wanted to dig into for a second.
I've been in a place in my life where
I've had no confidence, no self respect,
zero self worth and it was
really easy to hurt my feelings.
Anything would trigger me to be sad.
Then when you rebuild some
of that you become stronger.
So I was hoping you could describe us,
whether it's that episode,
that period that you talked
about or another and I just
one of the darker harder
times.
Sure.
And like what a day looked like during
that time and then the things you did or
the things that helped you get
out of that depressive state.
And it doesn't have to be depressive,
could be anxiety, could be anything else.
Um, well, you know,
and I still have days like that and I
think that's healthy for listeners or
watchers to understand that just because
something's going well or what pro,
you know,
what people perceive to be going well,
it doesn't mean every day is perfect and
I think the hard times in my life have
really shaped the good times in my life.
And I think many people can
agree with that. So, you know,
the inspiration behind bumble
was really driven from self,
you know, self experience and what I've
gone through in my life. Basically.
There's been a common theme with every
tough time I've ever gone through.
And that always comes
down to mental abuse.
And that has been not just in romantic
endeavors, that could be friendships,
toxic friendships. And so there's this
been this recurring theme. And you know,
when I was under so much scrutiny from
the Internet from strangers and I was
allowing these random strangers to
define me and to dictate my day.
Can you think of any particular example?
I've personally,
I can certainly think of certain
examples. I'm like, oh my God,
that one year when that thing came out
on my birthday and it was a hatchet job
piece is, can you think of one where
you're like, Oh God, that day. So
it was, it was actually right after my
birthday. Funny you say that. It was,
um,
the summer of 2014 and all of these
articles were running and I hadn't,
I wasn't speaking to anyone,
I wasn't commenting on any articles.
I knew nothing about the
media at that time. Nothing.
And I could not have been more naive
when it came to PR and press at that,
at that time. And yeah, there'd
be dragons. Got To be careful.
Yeah. And uh, you know,
this story came out one morning,
one afternoon, my dad sent it to me
and it was disgusting.
It was talking about,
you know, the, basically the,
the piece painted me as this,
um,
you know,
like at the gone girl of Tech, you
know, she was a seductress and Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, and all
of these awful, you know,
insinuations and it was talking about
ridiculous things like really personal
details that were completely inaccurate
and it was really gross and ugly.
And it just made me feel undressed. I
felt naked. Your Dad's commentary like,
well, and that was what
was so devastating. My Dad
was just like, you know,
having your father send you an article and
be like, is this true? Like, of course,
no, but what, you know, how do
you have to justify that at 24,
just turning 25 years old
to your father? What, how,
how can journalism be that? No one
asked me for comment on that. You know,
no one asked if those allegations were
true and to be this young woman feeling
like I was part of this
like mean girl club.
And you know that the girl that was,
you know,
being pointed at and laughed at
by a group of people. I mean,
it was awful with the rest of your
day look like I was devastated. I,
I actually became physically ill.
He's now my husband and thank God for him.
He,
I was having such a mental breakdown.
I was actually having a,
what they call it, clinical panic attack.
I was hyperventilating, I was distraught.
I couldn't breathe at my site was not
right and he had to take me to his primary
doctor,
like his family doctor and the doctor
literally had to prescribe me one to two
days worth of some. Well, I don't
know, I don't take any medicine.
I'm scared of even Advil,
but I think it was like
volume or something to Jay
to physically call me down.
I was having a mental breakdown because
I had no way to defend myself and I just
felt helpless and I felt literally
undressed on a huge stage and it was,
it was awful.
Yes. Not a great feeling at all.
And it's even worse. I mean,
it's even worse for women. It's bad
for men, but it gets even worse.
I think for women, it can be
terrible for men, don't get me wrong,
but it was talking about that
very misogynistic things that really only
apply to women and that's what made it
worse.
You know,
making insinuations about who I was as
a woman and my intentions as a woman,
not, it wasn't even about business,
if that makes sense. You know? It was,
it was very,
it was a very
salacious and exciting
compared to the business stuff.
So apparently so paint the picture,
they want to pick out some clicks.
No.
One thing I'd love to chat about because
it came up in a number of places when I
was doing homework for this,
and this is certainly not
uncommon among founders.
I know people think, Oh, when the times
are going well, you're doing well.
When the times are going poorly, you're
doing poorly. But a lot of founders,
even when they're starting
up to doing really well,
have a certain baseline of low
grade or high grade anxiety.
So plus,
so I've heard Peter that points
tell me this. It's the Internet,
so who knows if it's true or not,
but at some point you were waking up
every two hours to check your email or
you'd wake up at four 30 check your email,
then go back to sleep and wake up
again at six 30 I did that for years.
You did that for years
actually,
that has just now started to slow down
and I have you at one time been anxious.
Is that been a sort of an
emotional home of sorts?
Anxiety paired with drive
and ambition and passion.
I'm so dedicated to what I'm doing.
I can't explain it to you. I mean
it's just part of my blood at
this point and it's almost like a,
it's built into my system.
Yeah,
the anxiety has been really scary over
the years. And there's days where,
you know, I couldn't feel my fingers for
hours or I didn't think I could breathe.
I mean this started manifesting into
physical ailments and God bless my doctor,
he's really going to have to block
my cell phone number at some point.
But you know, it's scary. If you don't
deal with anxiety will take advantage.
It will take control over your life.
How have you dealt with it?
What are the habits or
routines or self talk?
Anything has helped you to keep it
from going from a fuel to a handicap?
Takes control. It definitely
has become a handicap at points,
but I would say 85% of
the time it's a fuel.
And actually back to the doctor talk,
um,
my doctor said something
really interesting to me and
it's something that stuck
with me. I said to him
one day, I was like,
I don't know if I can deal with this
anymore. My anxiety is just so extreme.
It's paralyzing me at certain points.
Do I need to get on a medicine?
Do I need to be medicated for this?
And he responded,
just keep doing good work.
It will,
it will recalibrate the way you feel.
And when I thought through that and it
was like, you know what, when I can just,
if I can channel this energy and this,
this anxiety and channel
it into doing good work,
meaning work that affects
others in a positive way,
it genuinely works.
It actually,
if you shift your focus to
shift it and you have to,
you've got to harness it and control it.
And my husband's great about this too,
you know, he's just like,
what are your thoughts?
Let's get your thoughts under control,
you know,
and how do we harness this and just,
focus on what's causing this and then
how do we shift it into something that's
positive versus you, you know, doing
the, the self doubt thing on repeat
with any type of help like journaling
or is it just a conversation with your
husband and are there any, when you
feel it starting to spiral, I mean,
do you have pattern interrupts
that you can use? You know,
I tried to get outside and take a walk
and then my phone and I've found that
that's really helpful.
And also sleep.
Nothing is more nourishing to your mind,
body and soul and a good night's sleep.
And I think if you can have
uninterrupted sleep for, even if you're,
if you're a person that's like, oh, I
only need five or six hours of sleep.
If you can try to have a good
seven, eight, nine hours sleep,
it really changes the game.
I've also observed,
and I think these are actually very
closely related in some people,
but that at least in the
for people with depressive symptoms going
to bed before or by say 11 o'clock mix
it very big difference. Absolutely
sure. The words, you know,
sleeping from 2:00 AM if you're,
let's say self employed and have this
ability or unemployed from to sleep from
say two to 10 is not the same caliber of
sleep that you're going to get from 11
to eight or 11.
So I'm going to flash
back to
books specifically.
And so I had read at one point a,
I don't think we're going to spend a ton,
ton, ton of time on this right now, but
you ask about your team's mood every day,
which I thought was very interesting
and having have them rank it. Uh,
but what I caught at the end
of this I was curious about,
so it says a box in the corner
contains copies of originals, subtitle,
how nonconformist moved the world by Adam
Grant and wolf tells everyone to take
one home so they can
have a group discussion.
Why did you choose to
do that with this book?
And do you do it with other books? Are
there other books that you've also used,
uh, for employees in the company or
two years whenever it might be? Yeah.
So Mike,
we were saying earlier,
Internet time is like different time
zone from every other, you know,
measure of time.
When we were doing that we were a team of
something like six or seven. I got you.
Great. We were really a tiny team.
We were still in our apartment,
in our conference room,
was in a bathtub and you know,
we were really just trying to keep the
wheels turning and I felt that a good
mechanism of kind of keeping everyone
as fast and as crazy as it was all going
can keep keeping everyone on some
form of a thread of commonality.
You know,
where there'd be something everyone could
talk about together that wasn't bumble,
right?
So how could we,
how could we have interesting conversation
together as a small team that wasn't
just like, okay, what are we going to do
with our downloads are about new product?
Are we going to do,
did it,
how could we focus on kind of
interesting insights from someone else?
And so we did kind of a poll early on,
what books should we read it together?
Let's try to do a book club together.
And this was one of those
pivotal moments of growth.
And so it did not last very long.
The Book Club,
the book love did not last,
but the intentions were good,
the intentions were good and everyone
really liked the idea of trying to turn
off.
Another purpose of that was I was trying
to encourage the team to turn off a
little bit at night. Sure.
And instead of, you know,
getting deep into your emails after
you've come home from dinner, open a book,
you know,
Reed did detach,
do something that is going to challenge
your mind in a way that you're not being
challenged all day long. And so that was
the premise of it all. And um, you know,
as you grow, we're now, we're
approaching 100 employees here soon.
It's very hard to do, uh, uh, a check on,
you know, how you're feeling every day.
You can't really go around the room with,
you know,
so many people and it's really hard to
get everybody together for book club when
things are just going so fast.
Yeah.
Are there any books personally that
you've gifted often to other people or
re-read allot yourself?
Yes, I have, um, several different books,
but to that we can talk about something
I've always gifted and kind of held
close over the years. Is the book
Shantaram have you read Shantaram okay.
I became obsessed with Shandra.
I'm like,
I tried to join the Shantaram
fan club line, like a book club.
It got weird for a second,
but um,
the point is I loved Shantaram and I
loved that it took you into this different
element of human understanding.
And I wanted my team to read it because
I think it's actually a great marketing
example,
how to build a product based on human
behavior and how to understand people
around you and what makes people tick,
not just what's the Roi on some billboard.
Right. Um, and so I don't know
what it is about that book.
I can't summarize it in one sentence,
but it just gives you a peak
into the soul of humanity,
if that makes sense.
And so that's a book that I've,
I've gifted frequently and I love
also the author has a really good,
effectively good by public world. You're
not going to hear from me for a while.
I'm going to continue to do my work,
but I'm not going to appear anywhere.
I'm not going to do anything.
And you've made this public proclamation,
which I thought was very inspiring. I
fantasize about that all the time. Uh,
but wow,
this book,
a very powerful story that
catches people very often,
catches people at the right time.
What's the second book?
So back to the right time when it
catches people at the right time.
I actually read that book. I,
when I graduated from college,
I went and got a backpack at Rei and
went to Asia for a couple to few months.
I have no concept of years or time
anymore. And while I was over there,
I spent time in Singapore and,
and throughout several cities.
But I also spent time solo at
orphanages in northern Thailand,
in Cambodia. Um, and then did a
lot of travel through that area.
And that was the book I read on that trip.
And so I think as you are sitting on
this bus that breaks down with a bunch of
local Cambodians eating crickets,
reading Shantaram,
you're almost taking yourself
out of everything you've
ever known to be true and
understanding how big and vast and how
great the world is around you and really
how small one is. Right. You know,
it just gives you so much perspective.
So that's one book.
Another book that I've
been gifting and um,
he should probably make me an ambassador.
So if he listens to this,
this book called the plant
paradox of you heard of it,
this will destroy your life in a good way.
But it's basically telling you that
everything you've ever heard about health
and wellness is completely false.
So he tells you plants are
bad for you essentially.
And I don't know what
it is about this book,
but it might be a little
bit of Hocus pocus, but I,
I'm a full believer and so I think I've
sent that book to like a hundred people
at this point. How has it
changed your behavior or? Well,
the big thing for me as I've been so much,
I'm also starting to understand
how health catches up.
So for the first few years of bumble,
I mean, I was drinking every night,
not at a club. I mean,
I have not gone out,
I've not been social like a normal 20
something year old since I started bumble.
Right? Actually, I became almost a hermit.
I became very reclusive and I just
wanted to be with my boyfriend who became
fiance now husband.
And I just wanted to be with people that
I really knew and trusted and I didn't
want to go anywhere because I was so
paranoid that everyone hated me or assumed
that these awful things about me
that I genuinely just went to work,
went home, maybe cooked dinner, maybe
cried a little bit, maybe drink some wine.
And that was it. And so, um,
this health thing has become
a bit more important now.
You know,
here you go to work and you can create
as much success as you are able to,
but you have nothing without your health.
You have nothing without
your mental health,
you have nothing without
your physical health.
And so that's why I'm kind of getting
into these, these, these books.
Um, because I think it's important
to have that type of balance.
Has it changed your diet or anything
like that? It actually has. It's,
it's scares you about, you know,
what you're putting in your body. So
it makes you think,
what is your diff?
What might a default breakfast or
lunch or dinner look like for you now?
Oh Gosh, yes. That's a crazy question. Um,
there is no default is
whatever I can find generally,
but now I'm going to be more thoughtful.
So the roles according to
this guy are that, you know,
everything you put in your body
as essentially your health, right?
And you are what you eat. And so even
getting a piece of organic chicken,
what you used to maybe think
was good for you. Well,
what does that chicken
eating, right? Yeah.
So it's just this awful rabbit
hole that you go down. But it's,
it's interesting and it's
important to understand.
We know the effects on
the planet and you know,
that's a conversation for another time.
All right, cool. I'll
check it out. Yeah. The uh,
everything you put in your mouth on your
body is a drug and it has a biochemical
effect.
So you have to think of it that way when
you sent the plant paradox and plants
are bad for you.
Uh,
there are a lot of plants that really
don't want you to eat them. Exactly.
That's what this is all about.
There are a lot of them. And uh,
made me think briefly,
I'm not going to get into a bit of Zuko
who is the Creator Slash Cook Creator?
I'm not sure which ofZ cash.
Cryptocurrency,
really smart guy who eats only meat,
does not eat any vegetables whatsoever.
And he's been doing that for years.
See,
because a lot of the plants have defense
mechanisms and they will poison you.
Yup. Yeah. They're, they're
learning to plants. I mean, Nice.
Since they are fixed in their mobility,
they can't run away from predators.
So they'd develop all sorts of very,
very, very clever defense mechanism.
Currently beans are toxic
for you. Yeah. Beans. This,
we don't have time to get into the
bean rabbit hole. The beans. Yes.
This is bins. This comes
up a lot. I'm not, well,
I'll digress for a second just because
you have very strict like militant Paleo,
which is like if you eat beans,
your GI tract will explode while
you're walking down the street.
Like you have to be, I'm exaggerating
a little bit there. They're like,
if you eat beans, it is like
swallowing broken glass. Uh,
I tend to, I tend to be more
moderate and my views of beans,
I find them somewhat helpful also given
their fiber content and so on for a lot
of things including weight loss. But,
uh, if you look at certainly, uh,
many different plants that have something
as seemingly innocuous to say oxalic
acid,
which is why you get that,
that certain feeling in your mouth
when you eat a lot of say, raw spinach,
which is,
can be somewhat innocuous down to
[inaudible] and other things that can,
they can actually do a fair amount of
damage. But we should title this episode,
bumble and bumble and
bumble and beans, uh, or bar in Austin
right next to me and
I'd cat. All right. Uh,
next question is what
purchase of $100 or less,
it doesn't have to be exactly that,
but what purchase that is not something
exceptionally expensive, uh, has,
has positively impacted
your life in recent memory.
It could be a few years ago, could be, um,
coconut oil, coconut oil, what
do you use it for? Everything.
You can take a bath with it. You can
put it in a smoothie, you can cook,
you can actually put it on your skin.
I think coconut oil miracle by,
yeah.
Yeah, I agree. Has some
really fascinating, uh, uh,
it's like antifungal antibiotic properties
as well. Anytime I curb, you'll,
I should say,
even if you get a cut,
they say you can put coconut
oil on it and it helps. Yeah.
Coconut oil is, uh, is really
fascinating on, on many different levels.
Useful for a bunch of diets maybe
that are contained and paradox,
probably not just because of the
concentration of MCT oil effectively. Uh,
but the thing you should always
keep one in your bathtub,
your bathtub, you can put a big
scoop of coconut oil in a hot bath,
nourishes your skin and it's actually
calming and relaxing and then you keep one
in the kitchen. Do everything
with it. Yeah, coconut oil,
almost used to cook it the other day,
but the burning point is, is not high,
not low.
It's around the same,
I believe are in the same as all the on
of like a smoking points around three 50
Fahrenheit.
Apparently oil's bad for you.
I don't want to go for cooking
groups is. Yep. Alright.
So olive oil varies greatly.
Uh,
your mileage may vary with
your olive oil purchase system.
Ferris brought to you by
the bunch you by bumble.
Uh, good, good answer. Uh, yeah.
Coconut oil also keeps forever. This
is a very useful to have around. Uh,
also
little, um, Smithson, um, journals,
the little, the little mini ones,
they come in yellow with a B.
I like to gift those to people on my
team and just their low price point.
I think they're like $60 for
actually a pretty big one.
And you can actually have it monogrammed.
Yeah.
And it's just a nice little
leather, um, notebook.
And I just think taking
notes actually is really,
really therapeutic and it's also
incredibly productive. I mean,
you'd be so shocked and I
know that you know this,
but I was so shocked when I started just
writing things down as they came up and
the stuff I was going back
to that I written down,
I would have never in a thousand years
remembered had I not written it down.
It's fascinating to see how much the
human mind actually just disposes of Oh,
in terms of memory.
And so I think that's a great little gift.
Yeah, it, it's really
powerful. And I mean,
you're kind of preaching to the
converted since I've saw many notebooks,
but I think as a guy,
especially there's this mental hurdle
with thinking of a journal is a diary that
I just can't sleep over, so I can't, but,
but if I feel like this is my activity,
yellow pages,
then it serves the same function really.
You have that chronicle and uh,
it's, it's true that we really think
we are going to remember forever.
The things that we will very soon forget
that was made so clear to me actually
when I was 15 my first time abroad with
any real time was as an exchange student
in Japan for a year. Totally changed my
life. Lived with Japanese in Tokyo. Wow.
Was the only, oh, so ended up the
only American in a Japanese school,
5,000 Japanese kids. So if you want to
talk about where's Waldo school uniform,
the whole nine yards. Yeah. It must have
been incredible. Every class in Japanese.
Yeah.
It was wild.
And I had these phone calls with my
mom catching up with my parents and she
would take copious notes every time after
we had spoken so that she could give
it to me later.
And I look back at those notes
and I don't remember 98% of it.
I mean now, now I do as a queue.
But if she hadn't done that,
all of those incredible experiences
just would have been gone. Wow.
That's fantastic. Uh,
it's really interesting.
When is the last time you cried?
Tears of joy yesterday. Yesterday.
Got some big news,
can't tell you about it unfortunately,
but I got some big news and I got
the news in my office with two of my,
you know,
kind of closest allies and very,
very early employees and key members of
the team and we all kind of freaked out
and we were screaming in my office and
HR came over and was like, what's wrong?
Everyone's worried or something, what's
going on in there? And I'm like, no,
everything's great. Can't tell you
what it is you'll see in a month.
But I'm actually cried tears of joy.
It's just,
it's awesome when when certain things
come up that you felt were so far away in
terms of them being obtainable
were actually happening,
but you've worked really,
really, really, really,
really hard to get there. Um,
when those two pieces
collide into actual reality,
it's just like such an emotional thing.
I also cried tears of
joy about a week ago.
So my husband broke his back in
an awful car accident a year ago,
exactly a year ago. And he had, you know,
they thought he was going
to be a quadriplegic.
They thought he was maybe going
to die in surgery, who knew,
who knew what was going to happen and he
was in critical condition for almost a
week and that hospital,
I mean I just didn't leave it.
I stayed in that Icu with him the
whole time and this year, a year later,
he was fortunate enough
obviously he's walking,
thank God and he's healthy and he's
well and we went back to the hospital
exactly a year later and
he very generously with his
family had donated the new
intensive care center at the
exact hospital and all of
his nurses that took care
of him for that week who were,
you know,
literally holding me as I sobbed and
was terrified that they came to the
ceremony.
And that was just the craziest feeling
to go from being in the darkest,
darkest,
darkest possible situation in a certain
building to coming back and being in the
best possible situation. That's just
like a really emotional situation.
So I definitely cried tears of joy that
that day. Where were you born and
raised in Salt Lake City, Utah.
That's what I thought.
So when you're going through this
experience with your husband,
you're at the hospital,
whether you're on the way there at
the hospital during that period,
were there any mantras or quotes or
prayers or anything that you relied on to
help or reminded yourself on? If it
doesn't have to be during that period,
but I mean work questions you asked
yourself. I'm just wondering if there's,
if there's anything that you go to
in moments like that, that you find,
you know, I do try to tap into
whatever the higher power is, right?
I'm not a religious person.
Um,
I do feel that I'm somewhat spiritual
and spirituality comes out in moments of
darkness, you know, or in moments
of fear. And it's interesting,
you almost feel this sense of security
when you feel the least secure of
possible. I don't know how to
explain that, but it's really spooky.
So actually the night before his accident,
I actually had a dream,
something awful was
going to happen to him.
And I called him that morning and I said,
I feel sick.
I was like six in the morning. I woke
him up early and I said, I feel sick.
I had this awful dream.
I need to come home.
Cause he was actually not in Austin at
the time and he was in Tyler where his
businesses and so home is kind of, we've
kind of commute is I need to come home.
I can't go to la today. I, I've got to get
home. I just don't feel good about this.
And he was like, chill out. Like
I'm going to go walk the dogs.
You go downstairs like how some
coffee call me on your way to work.
And I just had this sick feeling and
this really bad feeling like something's
not right.
Something's not right.
And I called him on the way to
work and he didn't answer it.
I just started sobbing in the car and I
had to kind of slap myself and both the
window down and be like,
you're having a panic attack.
Like this is so you had too much coffee.
And I just couldn't calm myself down.
And Lo and behold, five
minutes later, you know,
I got the phone call back from his,
um,
chief operations officer who
was following an ambulance.
And so that really stuck with
me through the whole week.
And I was trying to wrap my head
around that. I was trying to, you know,
decipher why did I, why am I
feeling those things? So my,
my message in that not to ramble
is that I genuinely believe ev,
every person on this planet has a sense
of intuition and it's learning how to
separate that from fear or anxiety or
panic and really listen to your gut.
And, um, I really think that, that,
that's what has gotten me to where
I am today is that, you know,
listening to your gut when
you can. And um, so yeah,
that was my only really mantra was just
to kind of listen to what was going on
and try to keep it under control.
So I won't go too far into this because
the people who don't already think I'm
crazy, we'll definitely think I'm
crazy, but I probably think I'm psycho.
I've been systematically reducing my
caffeine consumption so that there's less
noise in order that I can
better listen to those feelings.
Because I have found when I kind of
raised the level of volume and static with
adrenaline and other stress hormones,
it drowns out some of the
signal and my dog is all sudden.
This is not that uncommon.
I mean babies and dogs I think also,
but my dog is very much every time she,
she never barks,
she really rarely barks at anyone.
And if she barks are growls at any
journalist and member of the media,
what I've ignored it,
it is,
it has within 24 hours,
uh,
ended up that I should
have heated that warning.
So I'd use that as one
of my many checkboxes.
Of course I'm using using some
more left brain as well, but I am,
I'm valuing more highly the,
the less obvious,
less perhaps structured thinking because
the vast majority of our evolution is
not prefrontal cortex. Let's sit
down with a spreadsheet. Yep.
And so if you have a funny
feeling, yeah, yeah, it's worth it.
It's worth exploring that.
So
interesting you say that because
every time I'm like, damn,
why did I not do that?
Or why did I do that?
If I think back to when I made the
decision against our forest, something,
I always had the right answer,
if that makes sense. Yeah.
But then you go on the other way for
whatever reason and you've kind of like,
she had to listen to myself.
Yeah. And for anybody out there,
like even in business,
I think that's such a good way to
have the answers because a lot of
entrepreneurs we don't have the answer is,
you know,
even though I've had this amazing business
partner who has a lot of answers and
I've been able to tap into his knowledge,
there's still so many days
where I have no idea what to do.
And you're left with one thing
and that's your gut and that's it.
And you have to try to listen.
But I'm with you on the coffee thing,
like I've tried to have only one step
because I will literally start spinning
out of control.
So I'm with you on the toning it down.
Yeah. To end a Emmy for it.
For people who are wondering,
well how does that actually apply? How
do you listen to it? And yet in my case,
one of the clearest examples,
if I look back at the 70 to 90 startups
that I've invested in over a 10 year
period from like 2007 to 2017,
uh,
and a lot of those were
passive at any given time.
There are no more than like four or five
active needing my help. So it wasn't a,
it was in waves, certainly, but,
and not often make it as you know,
how do you keep track all of that?
That's a whole set.
We could talk about it with the whole
separate conversation. I call no bucks.
Well, I'll give you one once. One
thing that I borrowed from Japan,
actually this is getting
a little off topic,
but so there's something called the k
two in Japan where if you look at the
conglomerates,
the very often they will buy a company
that can be a supplier or customer for
another company within their portfolio
or that has some type of knowledge.
It can be transferred to other divisions.
Every time I looked at
a portfolio company,
one of the ideal boxes to check was
how much can they be helped by end help
another company in the
portfolio is in the portfolio.
Very smart way that decreases the,
it increases the efficiency,
uh, for everyone,
but also decreases the actual so heavy
lifting that I have to do as a solo
operator. Uh, but when I look
at all of those companies,
and there's the good, the bad and the ugly
within that, as you would imagine, uh,
the gut feeling and feeling good about a
company or feeling good about a founder
isn't enough for me to invest,
but feeling off about a founder's
enough for me not to invest.
And when an agreement,
right. So because every,
a lot of really good founders
are going gonna have a,
maybe not a Jobsian level
d reality distortion field,
but they're gonna be very good at
selling and there can be very good at
persuading. And if they're not, well,
guess what? That tells you something too,
because they're, they should be. Yeah. Uh,
so it's very easy to drink the Koolaid
even if you think you're immune to their
charismatic effects. So if I feel good
about it, it's like, all right, trust,
but verify. Let me, let me,
let's get some documents. Yeah,
let's look at the documentation. Let's
actually look into that feeling. But yeah,
exactly.
Whenever I've violated that,
which I did in some of the early cases
where it's like, well, we have this,
this leap that we have, all these
amazing investors were closing 48 hours,
we're oversubscribed. We can fill
you out. And all that Fomo Shit.
And then I invest on, and I'm
like, I fucking knew it. I
knew, I knew it within the,
not even the first hour,
like I knew within the first five minutes
didn't feel right with that person.
Okay. So that's enough. No, that's really
interesting though. Mumbo jumbo, but yeah,
just like good advice to people. Yeah.
Seriously passionate about stuff. Yeah.
There's a book for people who are
thinking about how this might apply more
broadly, uh, called the gift
of fear by Gavin de Becker,
which talks about this and how
people get themselves into very,
very awful situations.
Women,
especially often by not paying
attention to that feeling,
that nagging feeling.
It's really important to pay attention to
what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made.
And that doesn't have to be money. It
could be money, but it could be time.
It could be energy.
Uh,
anything that you've invested into
that gave you a tremendously high Roi,
best thing I've ever invested into his
time and dedication into my team at
bumble. Okay? 100%. The best thing
I've ever invested in. And you know,
it's been such a,
um,
dedicated effort over the
last three and a half years,
but really investing that extra,
that extra hour or that extra day
or that extra thought or that extra,
get to know someone. Right? Um,
that's the stuff that counts the
most because when you do that,
you instill more than just
a job opportunity. You know,
you give more than just
an opening at a company.
You really leave them with the same values
and the mission becomes ingrained in
them and they're able to do their job.
And in a way that is almost,
um,
immune to competition because there so
on the same page with why you started the
company to begin with,
what are, what are some ways
that you do that concretely? Uh,
whether it's in the onboarding
process or ongoing or otherwise,
like anything you do on a monthly or
weekly or quarterly or whatever basis.
W can you give an example? Yeah. Yeah.
So I think that your first 10 hires
are what defines the future of your
business. Because no singular
human can scale culture.
It's impossible.
There's no way to have the time or the
bandwidth or the actual physical ability
to go and instill your vision
and your values in, you know,
hundreds of employees as things
grow if you're so fortunate.
So those first 10 people,
they are your culture warriors.
And if you can invest everything
you've got into those people,
those people will then invest everything
they've got into the people that work
under them or you know,
beside them.
And that's how you scale
culture. And I'm so, you know,
in the early days we're talking weekends,
like I would do whatever I could
to make experiences for my,
my key early hires so that they
felt they felt like family,
but in a non boundary
crossing way, right. You know,
we still had boundaries where they still
had their own lives and we were trying
to keep things healthy. So, you know,
having everyone over to my house on a
Saturday and making sure that they had a
great day,
but really explaining to them my pain
points that I lived through in my life and
why this company's going to
make a difference and, you know,
share with them how we can actually
have real impact on the world,
not just a paycheck or the
potential to be a big, you know,
valuation one day.
Right.
How do we actually change the world
through what we're doing and changing the
world doesn't necessarily mean,
you know, uh, on the main scale,
you can change the world by
affecting one person, right?
That is putting good energy out there.
And so investing that mantra and
kind of putting that time and,
and really finessing that,
that ethos has served me very well and
I'm so proud of them because they're all
now leaders in their own right.
I'm,
I want them to feel like mini CEOs
of their own in their own way.
And you know, I, if I'm not
in the office for two weeks,
I don't want it to be like,
oh, the boss is out because no,
there every so many bosses in that
office and they're amazing and they're
passionate and they're inspiring and
they're just as impactful as I am right to
this company.
And that's how I wanted it to be.
What are some of the,
the rules are better
perhaps as the question is,
what advice have you been given by mentors
or others that has really helped you
in the early stages of building a company?
It doesn't have to be specifically
hiring but it, but it could.
And if that's too tough or just
maybe not an interesting question,
just advice that you've received from
mentors are key lessons you've taken away
from any particular mentor?
Yeah,
I've,
I've received a lot of interesting advice
and I think that the more you listen
and the more you absorb,
the better you are. Um,
as much as I've tried to say,
you know,
I'm going to do this my way and your
advice is nice and your advice was great,
but I'm going to trust my gut and I'm
going to build the company that I want it
to be. I have gotten great, um,
great pieces of advice from
so many people. And I think
that my business partner,
like I said, he had been in the dating
industry for almost a decade before me.
And so there were times I would
call upon him and say, Hey,
I'm thinking about doing
this. And he'd say, well,
I think you should think about it in a
different way because he had been through
it. And so, I know this
is going to sound silly,
but the best piece of advice I've
ever received was from my husband's
grandfather and he said the most expensive
currency in the world is experience.
There's nothing better than experience.
You cannot buy it. You can not pay for it.
You cannot go out and get it overnight.
So tapping into people with experience
and actually trusting them when you feel
that they're off base,
but really trusting them.
That's been such good advice that served
me so well because you've probably been
here too. You know, here
I am, this like, you know,
20 something year old a couple years ago.
I'm still 20 something year old,
but going out and doing
things my own way and saying,
oh well you just don't understand or I
want to do it my way or no, trust me,
it's going to be like this.
Tapping into someone who's done it before
and even if you disagree with them,
really thinking twice
before you shut them down.
And so I just think that served me pretty
well over the years is to not write
off people with experience.
And then for the more,
even if you feel like you're
strong enough to figure it out.
I mean certainly looking at
a lot of founders, I know
it can be very, you can feel
very isolating as a CEO and a,
I remember chatting with Amanda Palmer,
the musician much more than musician, uh,
certainly done a lot.
But if people search Amanda Palmer asking
for help or how to ask for help, it's,
it's extremely helpful.
She's given talks on this as well.
But I found it very empowering to
realize at times when I have artificially
isolated myself to be like, I don't want
to burden other people with my shit.
Like let me just figure this out and sit
down and play a notepad and get stuck
in my head and chase my own tail and self
flagellate and make this all worse and
then punish myself or feel upset when
I don't figure it all out. Absolutely.
And instead it's like, no,
your friends want to help you.
Like give them the gift of allowing
them to help you and your friends.
They don't have to be a friend.
Yeah. Even people that I, you
know, along the journey I'm,
I kind of have this syndrome where I,
I'm always impressed by everyone and I
don't feel impressive ever. It's just,
it's something I've suffered with my
whole life. And you know, I've just, I've,
no matter who it is in front of me, it
literally could be someone that, you know,
career wise isn't even on the same,
you know,
kind of contribution
level or whatever it is.
But I'm just always impressed by
people because I think it's so,
it's important to really appreciate
everybody else's, you know,
kind of story and where they've come from,
what they're doing.
And so I've always been the last
few years scared, like you said,
I've always been like,
well,
I can't ask that person for advice because
they're so important and they're so
impressive and they're gonna think I'm
annoying or they're going to think that
I'm needy or they're going to think that,
you know what I mean?
And so I've almost dug myself into this
hole of not asking enough people for
help.
Yeah.
And fear of them feeling
invaded or imposed on?
Not because I didn't care
about what they had to say,
so that's a really
interesting perspective.
Let me give just a couple of thoughts
for people who are like, okay,
I'm going to ask him for advice or ask
you for advice or whatever it might be.
If you're, if you want to ask anyone for
advice who you perceive as very busy.
One recommendation I
would make is do not say,
can I take you out to lunch and pick
your brain? No one has time for lunch.
Let's do the brain picking.
Sounds awful and nobody wants to do it
because it's really nebulous and so the
concern is I'm going to go
out to knock to be 15 minutes.
It's going to be an hour of them trying
to figure out what they want to say and
it's not going to be a good use of
time. So you can, if you can say a,
I know you have a thought,
I'd get a thousand email if you don't have
time to respond. I totally understand,
but I couldn't think of a
better person to reach out to.
Just one thing I'm really struggling with,
here's the situation,
here's what I've tried to do or figure
out already had this is this is this is,
I've actually used Google. Yeah, right.
I'm not going to hit [inaudible].
I actually looked into it. I've, I've
tried to figure out this and this.
This is where I am. Yup. Super specific
question. And again, if you're too busy,
totally get it. No problem. And
if easier, here's my cell phone.
I think that giving them an out
recognizing they're busier than hell,
which they probably are,
and having a really soft delivery but
showing that you've put in some work. Yes.
But you're not outsourcing your like
mechanical Turk stuff to them like yeah.
Do you put in some effort and
show that you've done that? So
a follow up to that.
We actually do that in the office.
So what I've told the team and what
the team has really learned in there,
they do it on their own, which is
amazing. If you have a problem,
please don't come talk to me about
it unless you have a suggested yeah.
Solution. Exactly. Yes. Absolutely.
I can't just listen to problems come
with two potential solutions. Like,
Hey Whitney, we've got a huge issue. Um,
this situation has completely crumbled
and we're committed to this or whatever
happened. My suggested solution
is either a, we do x, Y,
and Z or B, we could do this and here
are the consequences of both. Yup.
And this is what, um, is going
to happen in each scenario.
And then we can talk through that and it
goes to show that someone has actually
thought through, you know, the other side
of the fire. How do we get out of here?
What's the exit strategy? Not
just, Oh, we were in a fire.
Yeah.
This is so important.
And if you think of problem solving
as an algorithm or software in a way,
if you add head count to
say really inefficient,
a software development project is just
going to make things take longer, right?
So the more people you have, in a way
you could argue this is really important,
especially when you have a tiny team,
but the amount of bloat and wasted money,
uh,
that can really cause problems up
doesn't increase in a linear fashion.
When you then have a
hundred, 200, 500 people,
if you have 500 people who haven't
been coached on how to do this,
it gets even more expensive. And uh,
one thing I'd add to that is yeah,
this is so important. So when I hire
people part time, contract, full time,
whatever it might be,
they learn really quickly,
do not come to me a with a problem
without a proposed solution.
And if you come with a proposed solution,
don't give me a 12 item,
multiple choice questions. Yeah, you
can give me your top three or four.
I also want to know which one do you
think we should do and why this one is the
best and why have you gotten to that?
And I might disagree with it,
but it's like put them, I want your top
four options or whatever it might be.
Three in ranked order and for you to
explain why you think number one is the
best. Yeah. And then
it's a yes, no, right.
Or now let me take a closer look.
But it's, it saves so much time.
Uh, and I think what's important to,
to pair that with, and I remember, uh,
Reid Hoffman, so the cofounder of
Linkedin, among many other things. I mean,
the guy is incredible investor
and critical guys. Couple guys,
and I'll add, I'll add this. I mean, I've
had him on this podcast so people can,
can look it up,
but he's also age from what
I've experienced of him
and many people who have
experienced a genuinely happy guy.
It's hard to overstate how rare
that is among a lot of these folks.
You would use,
how many people try to get out there and
become successful as a, as a coping or,
you know, this is gonna make me
happier. This is going to make me happy.
And then they get to the next level and
they're still not happy and then they
want to go to the next level.
So that's brilliant.
Resumes. Yeah. And, uh, and he, uh,
I mean you taught Wittgenstein classes
at Oxford also like in his spare time.
The dude is amazing. He's done a lot.
And he was the fire, he was called,
he was referred to as the firefighter
in chief that's right by Peter Teal and
uh, read, uh,
hired a,
a young guy named Ben Casnocha to be his
chief of staff and to handle anything
and everything.
It's kind of like an aide to camp position
if anyone from militaries listening.
In any case, what he told Ben Really
early on was, and I'm paraphrasing here,
but you can have something like a 10
to 20% footfall rate footfalls just a
tennis or a sports analogy.
Like you can have a 10 to 20%
error rate for the sake of speed.
Like I want you to move quickly.
I want you to figure things out on your
own and like you're allowed to make
mistakes.
I expect you to make like
10 to 20% mistakes and just
try to not make this your
margin. And when you tell
people that and advance it,
it also manages XP to
help manage expectations.
And it helps to encourage them to do
what both of us are suggesting because
otherwise they're like, well, I'm,
if I'm afraid that I'm going
to be punished for making
every mistake or slight
error,
then I'm going to come to you with to
try to get your opinion on everything
because I don't want to get
that negative right. Uh,
suffer that negative consequence.
That's really interesting. Yeah. Yeah.
I read this study, uh, so
just, uh, just a few more, uh,
what is an unusual habit or an
absurd thing that you love and I'll,
I'll buy a little bit of time, uh,
because when I say absurd or weird,
I really do mean weirder. Absurd.
So for instance, and you know,
I take a screenshot anytime
my phone says five 55, because
lucky number five 55, I screenshot
at five 55. Are you serious?
I cannot ask my husband. I
screenshot. If anything is by 55, I'm,
I'm a Weirdo with the number five. If I
see a door that is like five, five, five,
I do the same thing. I swear to
you. That's crazy. I'm not kidding.
I promise I've ever run into anyone else.
I have a freak thing with fives.
All right. Well we've, the
universe has brought us here.
That's crazy. No. All
right. So that's one. Uh,
then you have someone
like say Cheryl strayed,
who wrote wild and a hugely impressive
woman's written a lot more than that.
She'll rearrange sandwiches because she
wants every bite to contain every layer
of said sandwich.
I could,
she doesn't want there to be a clump
of avocado on one half and so on.
I get that. Right. But
it's understandable. It's
still pretty weird. Uh,
so besides you're screenshotting,
what other odd habits or
absurd things do you do? I love
people think this is absurd. I just think
it's sweet. But, um, I guess I'm not,
I'm different.
I cannot sleep at night unless I text
my mom goodnight and say I love you. Oh,
that's sweet. I've been doing it since
I left home. I cannot sleep at night.
I have to like last
night I was so exhausted.
I had been doing south by stuff all day
and literally I had to roll over and get
my phone and say, Goodnight
Mommy, I love you.
I just can't go to sleep without doing it.
I know it sounds kind of crazy.
I'm literally a grown woman.
I was 28 years old. I just,
I just would never be able to live with
myself if the next day came and you
don't get to see your mom
again for whatever reason.
And I just have to say goodnight
and tell her I love her.
Great practice. And you could argue it's
even more important the older you get.
And that is, I would
recommend everybody, people,
people who have listened to
this for a long time, a podcast,
you're gonna be sick of hearing this,
but read the tail end by Tim urban please.
It really paints an incredible picture
in a sense of urgency as it relates to
interacting with your parents.
And I think the number is something like,
by the time you graduate from
a May even be high school,
I don't even think it's college.
You have like 300 days or something
that you've spent 80 plus percent of the
time you will ever spend with
your parents before they die.
Something like that makes
me like, and uh, so yeah,
I think more people should do that.
So yeah,
I guess you could call that upstart
because you don't hear a lot of a lot of
adults doing that.
So it's probably classified as absurd.
But I do think that it's important, you
know, and no matter how busy you get,
or no matter where you are in the world,
but what's more important
than your family? Nothing.
Yes.
Yeah.
That have a lot of close friends pass
away this past 12 months in it's,
and almost all of them are entirely
unexpected. So you just don't know yet.
You just don't know when your time is
up or someone else's. So don't Save,
don't save that stuff. Uh, in the
last few years, could be five years,
two years, doesn't really
matter. But what new belief,
habit, behavior, tool,
anything has most positively impacted
your life personally and not the company
that your employees, but you, is
there any new habit or belief,
uh,
breakthrough breakdown,
anything that has ultimately ended up
having a very strong positive impact on
your life?
That's a really good
question. Um, you know what?
Turning my phone off from time to time,
genuinely, that's helped me a lot.
I think I've this insane tech
addiction over the last few years,
just bumble is on my phone.
I mean literally everything
goes through my phone.
I'm communicating with people all day,
every day and it's nonstop.
And so turning it off,
putting it in a drawer for 30 minutes
is actually really helpful. All right,
so last or second to last question is if
you get put, can't be an advertisement,
but a word, a phrase, a quote, question,
anything on a billboard.
So metaphorically getting this out
to millions or billions of people,
what might you put? Well, we did it.
We put be the CEO your parents always
wanted you to marry and we put that on
bunch of billboards everywhere.
We actually asked that exact
question in the office.
If we could share one message with the
world and we had a budget to do it,
well we put up there and that was really
the sentiment that our team landed on.
It just speaks to everything
we're trying to do with bumble.
We want to encourage women to be equals
and to be seen as equal and in any court
ship through friendship or
business or love, whatever that is,
to really feel empowered and confident
and to get out there and be whatever they
want to be. Not Go and try
to find that in someone else.
You can find that in someone
else but tried to do within. Also
Whitney, thank you so
much. Thank you so much.
Where can people say hello to you?
Best places to wave a hand on the
Internet. Check out what you're up to.
As long as you're going to be nice on the
Internet, come to Instagram. Um, but no,
everybody
wolf heard and I would encourage
everybody to check out bumble.
We've added friend finding business
connections and everything.
So I think that would be a great
thing for people to go check out.
And for everybody listening,
I will link
everything in the show notes as per usual
and she can find a tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time,
thank you for listening and watching.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work
week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one. And if you sign
up, I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com the world's on demand
massage service.
I've been broken so many times over the
years that I usually have body work done
at least once a week.
I have a very,
very high bar for this type of thing and
I was very skeptical of sooth until I
tested them.
Not once,
but I would say at least a dozen times
around the country in different cities.
I do not accept anything less than
excellent for any type of soft tissue
treatment and I would not suggest that
you accept anything less than excellent.
So I can affirm personally
that sooth delivers a licensed,
experienced and above all effective in
my book massage therapist and the comfort
of your own home hotel or
office in as little as an hour,
so you can think of it as
Uber for massages available
and 55 cities worldwide at
this point across the US,
UK, Canada, and Australia,
so you can relax just about any time,
any where,
and I've tried many different types of
massage that they offer in the process is
super,
super simple.
Download the sue the APP that's s o o t
h e or go to [inaudible] dot com choose
the kind of massage you want.
You can slice Swedish sports,
deep tissue or even couples massage.
I usually do deep tissue myself or I'll
do couple's massage and then tell both
of the therapists that I'm actually
intending to get a four handed massage
instead of having two people get
to massages, if that makes sense.
Then you set the length of your massage,
whether 60 90 or 120 minutes.
If you're looking to get fixed,
I usually do 90 or ideally 120 you select
the gender of your therapist and then
boom, you're done and you will
see who picks up the call.
The service is available from 8:00 AM
to midnight and suit brings everything
that you need to create a spa experience
in your home and the therapist handles
all of this, the massage table, linens,
oils, music, the whole nine yards.
So try it out, download, soothe
and as a listener of this show,
you'll get $25 off of your first
massage when you enter the code.
Tim 25 all caps Tim two five again,
download the [inaudible]
app and use the code.
Tim 25 for your $25 discount.
This episode is brought to you
by fresh books, man. Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast
and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting
with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting
software design exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you.
And use by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track your time,
and get paid very, very quickly, which
suits the needs of a lot of freelancers,
a lot of bumps.
By putting the willows and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and
debit card so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your
fresh books in the right category,
so on and so forth. Makes
taxes easy, makes invoices
easy, makes your life easier.
And also in fact recommend a pdf.
They didn't ask me to
read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf
awhile back called breaking
the time barrier. Subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential
so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with
the service business and the story in
that Ebook, it's pdf is the short
answer is really, really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So bringing the time error,
checking out,
but also why not test out freshbooks?
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free
trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter Tim Ferriss, two r's and two s's
in the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very
little tracking. That's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com/tim and
tried out because it is a very good
product and I think you will find
it simplifies your life. Joy.